i'm jason blum for Fandango movie clips
and here are some things to know before
you go see the darkness the darkness is
about a family a mom and dad Kevin Bacon
and Radha Mitchell they have two kids
they go on vacation and on vacation the
son discovers this ancient woman and
takes some of the things back to the
house and as a result of doing that
terrible things begin to happen every
time you go to a museum to an outdoor
exhibit or anything and there's a sign
says do not touch do not move and when
you're a kid when you see do not touch
all you want to do is touch so I thought
what inspired me to make this movie is
this young boy finally does I think what
most young boys want to do when they're
told not to touch something not only
does he touch things he takes them and
the result is very bad this movie all
started with a coffee I had with Kevin
Bacon five or six years ago I talked a
lot to him about Ethan's work in
sinister and Ethan's work in the purge
and I thought we could do something
similar with him and I sent him a bunch
of scripts and he kept saying no until
he finally read the darkness and really
really connected with the part of this
particular father and what this father
would do in this terrible situation and
I guess the other piece to the movie
that made it happen for me is I've
always been a huge fan of Greg McLean I
loved Wolf Creek
Greg is a real is what's known as an
actor's director he's a really very
actor friendly director our movies are
inexpensive we don't have a lot of
special effects so most of the directors
that we work with are very actor focused
there's a theory which I actually think
is pretty true which is that the set of
a horror movie is a lot more fun than
the set of a comedy people who have not
made scary movies think that horror
skits are very scary and in fact there
are young kids and there are teachers
and there is catering and there's peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches as much as
I'd love to tell you that there were
real ghosts on the set sadly there were
not but there are in the movie our
company's model is low-budget and it's
low budget very specifically because if
you bring budgets down of movies you can
try new things and different things and
the darkness fits into exactly that
category the darkness relies a lot on
drama and if you notice the more
expensive scary movies rely on special
effects and big scares and our movies
don't rely on that they really rely on
drawing you into the storytelling by the
drama and
acting on the screen and then we do a
kind of simple scare and my feeling is
those scares are always much scarier
than a big scare with special effects so
the darkness is really a perfect plum
house movie my favorite scene in the
darkness is one of the grossest things I
could ever imagine which I'm not gonna
reveal here but I will tell you it
involves vomit and it's it's unique and
it's one of the grossest things I've
ever seen and it was one of my favorite
scenes in the darkness
if you liked insidious or sinister or
paranormal activity or the purge you're
gonna like the darkness besides the fact
that we've produced all those movies all
those movies have one thing in common
which is they have great dramatic
stories and what better thing is there
to do on Friday the 13th then go out to
see a scary movie